So, I'm 15 years old and I'm opening up a show in Hawaii called the "Magic of Polynesia."
I'm in front of a curtain and I'm singing songs, and my job in that show was to entertain...
...about a thousand people, a thousand tourists from all over the world.
And I would put together a set list like 10 to 12 songs...
...and I'll be honest, I was incredible at 15, I was.
And later on in life, I found out that those songs that I was singing...
...were written by either Babyface, Jimmy Jam, Terry Lewis or Teddy Riley.
And with those songs, I remember singing it.
I remember singing it firsthand, people dancing...
...that have never met each other from two sides of the globe;...
...dancing with each other, toasting with each other, celebrating together.
All I wanted to do with this album was that...
...and you know, those songs were written with nothing but joy.
And for one reason,...
...and for one reason only and that's love,...
...and that's all I wanted to bring with this album, and hopefully I could feel that again...
...and see everybody dancing and everybody moving.